world leaders are sharing mixed
reactions to president Trump's attack on
globalism during his United Nations
address the president highlighted his
america-first policies during
yesterday's speech saying the future
belongs to Patriots New Zealand's Prime
Minister Jacinda Dern is among the
leaders in New York for the UN General
Assembly her countries you know got
global attention for implementing strict
gun control measures after the mass
shootings in Christchurch back in March
earlier this morning we spoke to her in
an exclusive interview about her
closed-door meeting with President Trump
this week and what he thinks of New
Zealand's gun laws word is that our
president did express interest in the
measures that you implemented what can
you share with us about that meeting oh
there have been those who have been
interested in what and what happened in
New Zealand obviously after the 15th of
March where 51 lives were lost from our
Muslim community the sentiment was
really clear we we are a country who has
legitimate use for guns our farming
community particularly for peace control
and animal welfare issues but there was
a really a real line in the same moment
for us as a nation and a question was
asked you know why why do we need why
does anyone need military-style
semi-automatic weapons or assault rifles
and so that's where we drew the line
within 10 days we announced that those
laws would change within a month roughly
it was done and now we're in the middle
of buying back all of those weapons and
we've had 20,000 of them returned in
over 70,000 parts they updated the
president he haven't done that here in
this country what did he express an
interest in what you all were doing did
he ask a question yeah we had a policy
discussion he was interested in how it
had worked how it had been received and
and there are a few countries and I
referenced effect we weren't the first
Australia after a particularly horrific
massacre did the same and I think that
points to the fact that in both
countries we have these moments in time
where where our people ultimately our
people just see this this isn't right
and there was almost unanimous support
in our Parliament everyone bow one
member of parliament voted in favor for
what we did you get the impression he
wants to do that here I got the
impression he was interested
I would be seeking kissing anything
beyond that you said you don't know you
do not understand why the US has failed
to change gun laws all I know is how New
Zealand responded and how New Zealanders
felt and when they heard that someone
had been able to access those guns
legally and then make a very simple
modification to those guns to make them
absolute killing machines we are a
pragmatic people and I think the
response was well surely there's a way
we can try and prevent that happening in
the future whilst at the same time
maintaining legitimate use for
legitimate users on that point when
ideas like buy backs and gun bans come
up in this country one of the criticisms
and I know you've heard it in your
country as well is look law abiding
people are gonna give you the guns back
what the criminals and the potential
terrorists of people you don't want to
have these weapons it's not like they're
gonna listen to the band well I mean one
of the one of the points that we've
tried to make of course is that there's
only a very small proportion of people
who are licensed ever commit crime a
small portion but if the guns are not
stored properly cared for properly they
are the ones that can still enter into
the black market so there is a
connection there are you punishing
law-abiding citizens while letting the
criminals continue with their criminal
activity no I mean it's certainly the
perspective we've had from those who
have been part of the buyback as they
see this as the right thing to do and in
Australia you know they did see results
off the back of their by Beck scheme and
so I look to them and see that that was
a positive experience for them and for
us
actually there is just no rational
reason to have these in circulation we
didn't even know how many we had but
fact we've had 20,000 returned for a
small country of less than five million
people that's a big result for us during
his speech at the UN yesterday President
Trump said wise leaders always put the
good of their own people and their own
country first what do you see the role
of the US in the world right now and in
every lead it comes to the UN and puts
their position and all I can do is put
New Zealand's and we are we are a face
lien dependent nation and of course as
any leader I feel the drawer to make
sure that I do my best on behalf of New
Zealand but perhaps be
Kosovo our our isolation we're also very
aware of how the actions of others
impact on us we we take a global view
and we see the impact of our actions on
others be it climate change be issues
like nuclear testing we are increasingly
connected so you can be loyal and
focused on the best interests of your
nation whilst also understanding that
what we do affects others and I think
that's the perspective of New Zealanders
sometimes our president has been
criticized for what what is seen as
divisive rhetoric in this country how do
you think it's viewed on the
international stage look increasingly I
think and I'd make this statement about
any of us you know even if you're from a
smaller country like New Zealand you you
you can be shot on to a platform
depending on on what's happening in your
corner of the world the point I've tried
to make is that increasingly we're
actually all amplified within each
other's borders so nothing that we say
within our own countries anymore is just
limited to that we will hear each other
now and our peoples feel the effect of
that and I don't say that to point to
any one leader actually that's a duty of
care that we all have and in this
borderless worlds now I think we need to
be mindful that other countries here
kids hear it and and I would say have
impact does that mean that the
anti-immigrant strong border rhetoric
you hear in this country and you hear
from our president could have an impact
on your security stirring people up in a
way that could harm look I think the
point that I would draw back to is again
just New Zealand's experience the
alleged terrorists on the 15th of March
was Australian not from New Zealand
hadn't grown up there
made a decision for several reasons that
New Zealand was going to be his target
but we are we are increasingly a
borderless world radicalization and
extreme views can be sought and found
anywhere by the internet regardless of
where you live and so I think we need to
start thinking more often about the
impacts and the ramifications of that
the Christchurch shooting was was
live-streamed by the shooter
so you see you you created the
Christchurch call to action basically
challenging to help eliminate terrorist
rhetoric on the Internet are the leaders
of
online companies are they are they
responding yeah yeah you know I I think
actually if you start with a safe a
simple premise like should we have
violent extremism and terrorism online
the the murder of 51 people broadcasts
live no one's going to think that that
is that anyone has the right to do that
and so that was our starting point and I
found the tech companies completely in
care engaged of course they want to make
sure that they maintain a a free and
open secure platform for people but they
can also see there's a line to be drawn
and so they've been really constructive
we've now generated some tangible
outcomes one of which is a crisis
protocol basically a civil defense
response if this ever happens again that
we can respond quickly you're right of
course it is a remarkable thing to state
out loud that Facebook livestream the
killing of 51 people and yet the US
government has not signed on to this
call to remove extremist content what's
the rationale that you've heard oh look
there might be many reasons why they
haven't formally signed on but actually
in reality what do they tell you oh
actually in reality that they engaged in
reality they have been working really
constructively with us and you will see
the time that the call was released they
actually made a supportive statement so
I understand that there may be issues
around free speech and otherwise but
actually it hasn't stopped the practical
partnership with being able to form only
23 of the 193 UN member states have
female leadership why do you think the
number is so low then what do you think
are there consequences when you don't
have more female leaders well I'm
particularly inclined to try and create
and this really sees or this click you
know I think these lots of reasons you
know I reflect back in my own region
we're doing what we can to to lift the
pipeline ultimately if you're going to
have female leaders you need female
members of parliament and female
politicians it's not a particularly
enticing place to be and so I I say my
staff
point is how can we make politics feel
like a place where you can make a
positive contribution and so that's part
of my philosophy is to tell the stories
of why and how we can do good for you
Prime Minister people doubted your age
they doubted your experience they
doubted whether you can do this job did
you ever doubt that yourself perhaps yes
[Laughter]
but in fact that's actually a
perspective there's so many women take
you know when I think about Helen Clarke
I've had of course I'm the third female
prime minister when I think about Helen
Clarke who was a past leader she even
talked after she left politics about
questioning whether she had the
credentials to then go and work at the
UN there is a I think a natural tendency
particularly for a woman to wait until
they have every skill required and so
it's about looking past this so how did
you get through that yourself no no I
knew that a job had to be done and I did
absolutely believe I could do it I did
but to Gail's question before what do
you think the consequences for the
entire world are when we have so few
women leaders well first they wouldn't
want to make an assumption that just
because you're a female that you'll
produce particular political outcomes or
policies everyone comes from their own
perspectives you know and I don't mean
to draw too many assumptions but there
will be times when we'll might choose to
do things differently and you're always
everyone brings their personal
experience to the table and so
particularly you know I think if you
come as a as a mother as a carer it will
influence the way you look at the world
in issues one of the most talked-about
probably the most talked-about moment at
the UN this week has been the speech by
credit tune Berg a 16 year old
challenging the leaders of the world
should you think she made an impact yes
I do do you think the world leaders
heard her well I certainly did and I'd
like to think that we had heard her some
time ago but it was whether or not
everyone that need to hear at any given
time we're all in the room we need to
hear that generation
and they don't want speeches they do
want to know that we're taking it
seriously but on the subject of taking
it seriously we're at a moment where
global emissions which warm the planet
continue to go up in your country and
ours a report came out just this morning
suggesting a billion people could be
affected by rising sea levels tied to
global warming your daughter my children
our families how are they going to judge
this generation your generation of
leadership on their action on climate
change
Ashley if we don't eggs which is why you
know I'm really proud of what we've
managed to do in a short space of time
half of our emissions come from our food
production so we're trying to lead the
way and becoming the most sustainable
food producer in the world and if we
figure out how to do that then we've got
technology and practice that we can we
can share with the rest of the world but
ultimately this is something that we
don't have a lot of time but no one
should feel powerless even if a
political leader of any given country
isn't taking the action that the
citizens expect you can at state level
at company level of course the private
sector has a huge role to play here no
one needs to feel like they have to
stand still and wait for political
leadership there's something that all of
us can do on this I want to ask one more
question about guns because I marvel how
you were able to change the laws in ten
days how were you able to do that and
what kind of opposition did you have to
it you've touched on it briefly but yeah
what did you say what did you do yeah
without parliamentary process it took in
me in just a bit longer they may but
you're right within 10 days we announced
the change and the plans for the change
and we got the ball rolling and you know
I have to say when I was first briefed
on the guns that were used by the
alleged terrorists and how easy it was
for him to obtain those guns I didn't
check with Parliament whether or not I
would have enough votes I just went down
and said gun laws need to change and
they will and felt assured that if the
rest of the country and my fellow
parliamentarians knew what I knew that
they would be with me and they were we
are pragmatic people and when we had
that experience we'll be united and
wanting to see change
all right I was needs very busy we
remember that made national news when
she was born because you brought her to
work and yes well look at her I worried
I may be a toddler now there would be
other additional news thank you so much
for taking the time and thank you thanks
to you